what you see is the actual reality of
the landscape I was exploring the lake
at kawah ijen is a bright turquoise
steaming pool of acid the gas vents
called fumaroles which blast hot Sulphur
gas stained the surrounding landscape of
bright yellow and the ignited sulfur
burns with a blue flame my name is Ruben
Wu I'm a photographer and a filmmaker
from Liverpool UK but currently based in
Chicago the blue flame is too dimmed to
be seen in the daylight so I had to wait
until dusk for it to be seen and the
moonlight was dull enough to show the
flames as well as reveal the surrounding
landscape I also used long exposures and
many of my images which allows for
pictures which show an extended period
of time
rather than a split second it is pretty
dangerous inside the crater it is
actually forbidden to venture down there
but people do it anyway there is no real
trail into the crater and I found myself
inside a yellow gas cloud for most of
the time which can burn your lungs if
you breathe it in and also smells really
bad I made sure to bring a respirator
and a pair of good goggles without them
you're pretty much blind and unable to
function I found myself thinking more
about surviving potential danger rather
than being creative looking at the
pictures now I tend to forget the
adverse conditions I have to shoot under
I mainly remember it being a unique and
solitary experience experiencing not
just the blue fire sulphur at night the
most beautiful sunset behind a lake full
of rising steam